yes we are sir uh kevin ryan
okay thank you good morning everyone
welcome to uh star
joint committee meeting on the 16th of
december uh
this is uh last meeting uh of this year
and obviously the one before christmas
so you'll spot trees in people's
backgrounds and
hopefully a bit more of a festive spirit
as we go through the agenda
uh would you start at 10 o'clock it's 10
05 so we're just
slightly over um fabiola can i just
check first item on the agenda
attendances have we had any apologies
for absence
we have received apologies from uh de la
fevre but
the machar pulled from legal introverted
here thank you
okay thank you uh minutes
of the previous meeting uh we're to
receive these and approve them if
they're a correct record are people
comfortable with the minutes
yes i am sure okay
we've seen nods around the room that's
okay
nice three declarations of interest if
you can give any notice of interest in
any
uh items in the agenda in the usual way
either declare them now let us know
uh after meeting something to the
offices so that we can have a look
um item four
uh the quarter two progress report
lorraine
it's actually nicola or elizabeth
nicholas
thank you i'll just try and share my
screen
you all see that on the screen now
we can yes great thank you
so i'm just going to take you through
this is the quarter two five star
performance report
um this is how we report to you on a
quarterly basis on this
um just starting with the commercial um
the savings at the moment
we are um running at 2.8 million up to
quarter two
so we're about halfway there towards our
targets
we have been working hard in quarter
three and quarter four to eight
and we'll continue to in quarter four to
obviously increase that and to hopefully
achieve
our target 5.6 million and we have also
been doing some work
with um finance and commissioners and in
all our councils to try
and um plan on forecasting next year as
well because obviously we understand the
importance of savings in this current
climate so
we're on progress so far for this year
that means in terms of the return on
investment our target is
two times return on your investment we
are currently running at 1.7
um return on investment so we have
covered our costs
so far this year and we're very close to
achieving that two times
return on investment i'm pleased to
report
in terms of income as we reported in
quarter one this has been affected by
covid
the normal income streams just haven't
been available in the first couple of
quarters of this year
um so we are now running at 100k out of
our target of 150k
and we'll be working hard within quarter
three and quarter four to try and
increase that
and to achieve that target um elizabeth
will talk more about that in the
budget which is later on on the agenda
but we have had some good news recently
we've been awarded a place on an espo
framework which is a national framework
and we're the only public sector
organization on there and i've already
had our first request
to support call-offs from that framework
i'm pleased to report
in terms of communities and social value
in particular in quarter one we reported
that
the um what we'd achieved was lower than
our target and that we're going to work
towards
that in quarter two i'm pleased to say
as you can see from the upward
trajectory
of the chart here we are now
very close to our target of 25
so we've managed to pull that back this
quarter
local spend and as you can see that does
vary
and this is done on a monthly basis you
can see it does vary month by month
but we are now above the target of 50
percent at 52.6
and it is something we've worked really
hard on in terms of our 10-point plan
which we brought to the last
joint committee in terms of supporting
our local businesses
and smes and then compliance
again we had a bit of a dip in quarter
one but we've pulled that back
up and we are working closely to try and
increase our verified spend
we have a monthly process in place for
this now
and we're close to the target and we
will continue to push this
throughout quarter three and quarter
four
are there any questions on that
thank you very much uh nichola so we're
just being asked to note this report
uh today but does anybody have any
questions can i see any
hands up
uh well michael is it's just uh why is
it that
social value down is it due to core with
19 or is there any other factor
yes we think in quotes one in particular
there was so much uncertainty in the
market that
suppliers were unwilling to commit to
social value because they weren't sure
what they could commit to and how they
could deliver it
what we have done is introduced the
covid plug-in which gives suppliers the
option to change to more coverage
related
social value and so we've i think that's
why we've seen the increase in quarter
two
okay thank you and i think
chair sorry if i can yes go ahead yeah
thank you not a question but
i think given everything and i i
probably said something like this last
time
i'm surprised how well we're doing um
and i think that's reflected in in
councils
um because uh it shows remarkably
remarkable resilience um in in
everything that's going on
um but i think the comfort i take is for
perhaps seven 785 to 90
of the population it is very much
business as usual so
i think the points that nicola's been
making about um you know
being able to hit targets and being
close to them uh you know
given the start we had is very
reassuring so
uh i look forward to quarter three and
uh and a successful year in due course
thank you council mega i i do agree with
your comments and i think it's
you know there's the the facts beats
themselves don't they into the
statistics and that it's obviously been
a difficult year but i think in
comparison to
other public sector organizations we've
done remarkably well i think that's
testament as you say to the team
uh councillor ross
thank you very much chad um again
similar comments i i think given the
year that we've had it's it's
it's remarkable what's been achieved for
both star and for local councils
um i also just want to stress the
importance of the
local spend element particularly as we
hopefully go into
recovery though that is questionable
with the way things are going with both
covert and brexit
but it it's so important more than ever
that we get our local spending and we
keep that money within
within our areas as much as possible
[Music]
absolutely absolutely thank you
councilman nicholas you want to come
back on any points that were raised
there
um no i think it's we have worked really
hard as a team
um obviously i think quarter one was
probably a more difficult quarter
um i'm being quoted too we have
certainly felt like we've got more back
to
business as usual so which has been a
comfort to all of us i think
thank you very much i think on behalf of
everybody on the committee for all of
your work across this year and
you know the statistics say one thing
but actually on the ground it must feel
like a different experience so thank you
for keeping pushing through this period
uh despite those pressures and
challenges
okay so that was item four at the
quarterly progress report um i'm going
to be on to item five
star procurement strategic strategic
risk register
uh who's taking us through this that's
me again
thank you nicholas um i should just pull
that up
i need to close a couple of things down
before i can open that up
would you like me to share it um nicola
um i think it's i think i've just had
too many
reports open but i think i might just
have got it now
yes i've got it thank you
so they're going to take you through the
um star risk register
and we update this on an annual basis
um and report well we update it on a
live basis but then we
update board and join committee on an
annual basis
or by exception so we have done a
comprehensive review of this in this
quarter
um not just as part of our annual review
but obviously to reflect the
um the risks associated with covid as
well
the thing i just want to draw your
attention in particular to the heat maps
which shows that there have been there
has been an increase in risk and an
increase in the more severe risk
um overall and that is a reflection of
covid
in particular the report sets out
the new risks that have been added what
we've removed and those risks that have
increased um no risk of decreased in
scoring unfortunately
so the um we this has been to board
um and they are happy with the content
and
so any questions on the risk register
thank you very much tickler if we could
use the hand function that would help to
just order some of the questions that
come through people are
able to do that i've still got counselor
ross from maybe from last night maybe
this new question
council ross it's what we call a legacy
hand now so i'll put it down
[Laughter]
thank you any more questions or comments
on the risk register
council mcgee i can see your physical
hand so we'll go with that instead
yeah i can't find a mechanical or
digital one
um so um i think i think the additions
of the new
the new risks particularly um about um
home arrangements because i think one of
the things we're looking at i'm sure all
all of four of us in our various
councils are
you know we've moved from something like
12 months ago 200 people
working at home because a variety of
things to over 2 000 people
and you know we know that for some
people
it's fine and for others it isn't
because of a variety of reasons so i
think um i think one of the things that
we're trying to do is an assessment
and i'm sure all everybody's doing that
an assessment of
what impacts could it have uh on the
organization
as a whole if we don't get these um
either home working arrangements for
those that can
or alternative working arrangements for
those who can't
um because it may well be that we have
to have some sort of work hub
somewhere or you know where people can
go because
home isn't suitable for a variety of
reasons so i think that's a really
important risk that we need to carry
forward
and the other thing that strikes me um
is
um and the point was made earlier about
we need to be looking to secure income
and
you know particularly in these uh
straightened times i think there's going
to be much more
uh much much much more careful looking
at procurement issues
and you know how can we do a deal with
uh
with anybody in some cases um so that
that that also might be something that
that's in stars sort of um
uh expertise and ability to sort of
to grip if you want them and and carry
forward
so thank you thank you councillor maggie
nichola do you want to come back on that
point yeah so just in terms of homework
it's something that we have been
monitoring as part of our wider
leadership team
in fact we had a discussion this week
about what we want to do in the new year
to help keep that staff morale
particularly in the dark winter months
of january and february just to sort of
keep everyone's
morale up and so we've talked about
things like walk and talks
um where possible obviously to meet with
staff and to have that
that physical meeting where we can um
rochdale have also kindly offered the
use of their offices
for us because we still have some of our
desks in different buildings
so myself and a colleague are going
tomorrow to see how we feel about being
in the office
that's one of the members of staff that
is struggling a bit working from home
and in general where staff have been
struggling traffic have been fantastic
at
um giving us the option for those staff
to work from the council offices as well
so thank you to everyone well that's
good to hear that because i think that
you know the assumption the assumption
has been
oh it's all right people can work at
home and that's true for many but not
all and that's the point you're making
so
well done to everybody
thank you uh council mcgee and thank you
nichola
are there any more questions on the risk
report no just the comments
yeah it's it's just that um
in russia we've looked at um
and then some of the staff doesn't have
adequate space even at home
uh and then that that's more of a bme
stuff where the larger families for
example
my my own i'm it's not a case working by
my own home
my wife is um who i tell
she's on that shielding and my mother's
91
by the way she's going in for the jab
today she's very excited
very good congratulations
she's got dementia i've never got two
children who
supposed to work from home and they
can't because she'll come
up and she's just come up to me and she
says oh who are you talking to you know
and um obviously
they have they have to move away and
work from somewhere else so it's a fine
balance
um and then we've done that with the
with the contact centers in
number one riverside people do come in
and at that you need
to be looking at that um
thank you council valley nicholas you
want to come back on that
i think lorraine's got a hand raised
also i think she might want to respond
i thank you chad i don't know where the
electronic candies either so i had to
use my
my own hand thank you chat um it was
really just to respond to
um councillor mcgee's point um
particularly on
um obviously we all know what we're
dealing with at the moment and we don't
know when the end will
will come and there's many many factors
that play out about procurement
efficiency
more procurement collaboration needed
and i think the wider agenda of sharing
and shared services both formally and
informally and
i just want to log really with um joint
committee that we've been approached
very recently by a number of um
organizations public sector
organizations both regionally and
nationally
and who are actually seeking help in the
shared service arena
um we you know we know we're a very
successful shared service that has grown
our numbers stack up in terms of our
outputs
and performance and i think what the
public sector are now looking at
um certainly from the contact we've had
is that the looking at ways that
efficiency can be drawn by sharing
because
even just sharing a manager brings a
cash saving on a simple level but
actually looking at efficiency through
process
and and practice so we we have found
that we we have been approached and the
lga have put two organizations onto it
in the last couple of weeks so there is
definitely a drive for people wanting to
learn and possibly commissioners into to
help with that
change agenda as we move forward so i
just wanted joint committee to be aware
of that thank you
fantastic thank you lorraine i think
it's obviously good that we've got a
reputation but also good that we can
deliver some
tangible savings and changes to people
as well and i think you know
growth is the future of this
organization and hopefully we will
continue to do that
um as long as we're all we're all still
here and you know we've got parana
and ourselves to do it um i just have
one question on the risk register
uh there's a there's a line in here
about
um the national agenda eu withdrawal
brexit arrangements
impact on supplier sourcing of supplies
uh impact on star partner saving
objectives
and i i realized that there's probably
been
a bit of hypothetical work done here
about the scenarios for an ordeal brexit
what impact do we think that would have
in terms of our own
supply networks um and i realize it's on
the risk register anyway and there's
been some there's been some work done
but what's the sort of potted
version of that elizabeth oh lorraine
yeah
yeah thank you oh go on lorraine i'll
let you no no no
feel free um terms
we've looked at because what we do is we
um we manage the food contracts for all
the schools across gm
um so i think that's where the biggest
impact will be
um and we're working closely with our
partners on that
to see what that that what that
potential risk could be
um in terms of non-food delivery or
uh food not being available or um you
know when we get to the summer season
the picking
etc so um we're we're like i say we're
working with our partners across gm on
that and we can bring
as and when that is finalized we can
bring that back to uh
to joint committee and and let you
everybody know
um lorraine yeah lauren and i've got
councillor mcgee
thank you chad adjusted up to that
really i suppose from a strategic point
of view and
looking at it locally regionally and
nationally and beyond
is um we are in the loop with the lga in
particular
looking at um obviously a green paper
that's been drafted and is currently out
to consultation
and we are privy to intelligence around
potential changes that will simplify
and eu regulations hurrah um
and actually look at very much focusing
them on on more local regional and
approaches to procurement so
i just feel they've just looked at what
star have done over the last few years
and thought oh that's a really good idea
why don't we make that the national
way of doing business so we will take
full credit for it of course but
on on a serious note it can only push
and and strengthen and i suppose um
[Music]
in i suppose a mandated way encourage
more behavior like we behave in star to
make sure that that local agenda is very
balanced
and it was interesting because i was at
stockport audit committee last week and
members you know were quite interested
in this point
and what they were looking at was
actually what is the impact in terms of
you know great that we're increasing the
local spend and
but actually are we are we excluding i
think yorkshire was the example
and you know a yorkshire business that
might give us a better deal but
i just want to assure people that we
look at quality we look at price
and we look at social value and then we
monitor the engagement that comes from
the voluntary sector
the engagement that comes from smes and
the engagement that comes from greater
manchester businesses
both in terms of bidding and winning so
you know we're all over this and it will
be great to have that legislation in
place that gives us
more freedom to mandate this type of
approach
thank you thank you thank you lorraine
uh i think some mix there about whether
we've
really taken back control or not or
whether this freezes up or what we won't
get into that today
council mcgee thank you um
by coincidence there was a ministerial
uh webinar yesterday afternoon from
mhclg
and uh and mainly on brexit uh
preparedness one way or the other we
won't go into the the discussion
but what featured was uh procurement and
food
um and particularly um
food competent certified officers which
i'd never heard of um
apparently there's a hundred of these uh
around the country and
and i think that links into the
pointless bit you were making about um
you know uh making sure we've got the
supplies and the fit
you know fit for consumption etc etc but
there's some guidance coming out
apparently it said shortly so read into
that what you will
um but shortly on all of this which um
i know will be interested in in
stockport and looking up because it
it has impacts for lots of minor bits
including our
license excuse me our environment and
mental health offices
as well so thank you of course
yeah thank you councilman mcgee
elizabeth you want to come back on that
mute yeah thank you and i'll look out
for that guidance and and share that
with the group as well
so thank you thank you okay so i think
are we done with comments questions on
the risk register agenda item
i'm not seeing any more hands we're just
being asked to note this today so people
are we comfortable to note that yep see
nods around the room that's good
thank you
and counselor ryan you're on meet
thank you sorry for that having a whole
conversation with myself here
um
star procurement continuous improvement
update
okay this will be a joint delivery
between myself and
nicola do you want me to share the
report nicola
oh no she started sharing already
sorry i had to work out how to unmute
myself whilst i was showing my screen
then
so yeah you've got a double act now from
myself and elizabeth
um this report is to basically just give
you an idea of some of the things that
we're working on in both the delivery
and the development side of the of star
around continuous improvements and what
we're doing to try and
continue to create an effective and
efficient service to you all
so first i just want to go through
tableau which
you saw earlier on the um in the meeting
which is
where we showed the performance
management dashboard
tableau is now fully implemented within
start and we use it both for that
performance management but also for
financial data management so
particularly our spend data
so we now have monthly monthly processes
in place
where we can look at our spend look at
the off contract where it's local
social value we've got it all linked
into that and
that helps feed into our monthly work
plan so we can plan resources
accordingly as well
hopefully most of you will see me held
our first virtual meet the buyer events
in november
that was due to be hosted at old
trafford cricket club and
um clearly got um postponed from june
but then moved it to november and then
obviously moved to the online virtual
format
this was a completely new way of running
the event for us
um so we decided to take the opportunity
to change the format of the event
entirely
instead of having a one day events we
held it over the course of the week to
coincide with the ever-popular world
procurement week
so we ended up doing 25 sessions
including top tips for tendering
social value ethical procurements and
also got some of our
main contractors to come along and
provide overviews of subcontracting
opportunities as well
so we have nearly 600 bookings and we
have had fantastic feedback so we sent
feedback forms back to everyone who
attended
and the the feedback has been great it's
been
they did miss the sort of physical
meeting of our buyers
but they appreciated the fact that we're
still able to put an event on
and actually when we've um shared this
with the local government association
they said that they weren't aware that
any other authorities were doing market
engagement in this way
during kobe so i think that's fantastic
and actually it's just part of
our business as usual so we've held a
market engagement event for some of our
bigger tenders
including over 100 attendees at some of
those
so that's really good to see
we've also been working on our data
because clearly we have a wealth of
information and data
um about our supply chain our markets
our spend our outcomes
so just to ensure we've got some
consistency and confidence in our data
we've developed data protocol
which is an internal data protocol for
us to manage our reporting
then just to give you an update on the
business plan that we brought to you
earlier this year we are still um
looking to launch that business plan we
just felt that it didn't feel we weren't
about
ready to launch it when we went into the
second lockdown and we didn't feel it
was appropriate to be launching a new
business plan at that time
so we are working now with trafford
comms and market
marketing team to get that formatted and
designed and we're looking to launch
that now in january
as a positive good news story to start
the year
and then the other thing to draw your
attention to is intend which is a
contract management system
um we are we have now procured the
system
and implementation will be in two stages
so at the moment we're just working
through getting our contract registered
uploaded onto the system
and then in the new year we'll be
working with the council leads
to fully implement the contract
management system
to commissioners throughout the council
i think at that point as my voice is
going um i'll hand over to
elizabeth i could hear that nicolas and
you want a quick drink
yep so um in terms of social media value
what we have done
is undertaking a tom's assessment themes
outcome measures
on our own team um and worked out what
social value we deliver
as a team and um pleased to announce
that
over 1.1 billion pounds worth of social
value is delivered
as as the star team and we've also
completed the social media value
maturity index assessment um
and fabulously have been graded as
um an innovator so our our maturity in
terms of social value now
um is the highest it can be in terms of
that
index assessment we've worked really
hard to get to that point and
you know we've put a lot of work into
social value over the years
and we're really proud to um get that
result
um we're also looking at improvement
always looking at improvement but um the
social value portal
has been in place now for um probably
well
18 20 months um so we're looking at the
reporting now and seeing how we can
well we can improve that from the portal
and to include bain
sme and split by local and regional
spend as well and we should be seeing
that from quarter three onwards
so we'll be able to share that okay in
terms of oxygen
um oxygen is progressing well the the
scheme was on hold during um
kovid and the um supply relief scheme
was was issued through
through the government so um as of the
first november it has been relaunched
across the partners that that are using
oxygen um
there's just some little tweaks we need
to do now in terms of evaluation but
we're well on the way
um we're delivering that that scheme
so that's everything that we've done
moving on to
uh continuous improvement and our future
plans nicola
yep so we've been looking at our website
and we wanted to launch
a new website and to make it look more
professional as we
in particular focus on the growth agenda
and this has
um coincided with the new accessibility
requirements for websites so we've been
working through
that with trafford council it
departments
and as part of that we have also been
looking at digitizing some of our forms
so
to facilitate more efficient processes
with
exemptions and procurement initiation
documents for example
so work is ongoing with that
i think back to you elizabeth back to
back to me around social values
to me to you this um so we are working
on a
social value strategy and what we're
trying to do is map the gm social value
framework that was launched last month
um across our four council partner
priorities
that will help us target specific
outcomes through our procurement
activity
and we're also working with traffic
councils to support them and becoming a
social value organization
so that the tom's assessment that i
mentioned earlier we're doing that with
a number of teams within traffic council
and also i've taken um the team through
the
social value maturity index as well so
we'll be
uh publishing the results of that soon
um once we've got that established that
will be rolled out across our other star
partners
um it will help trafford understand
their maturity
and then provide an action plan of how
they can drive social value forwards
um through all their part all of their
business not just through procurement
um hopefully this will lead to an annual
uh social value statement across all our
partners um and as i've said the the
social value reporting review is
underway
and what we're looking at now is because
all um
all of our procurement over 50k goes
through the portal we're looking how we
can um
extend that now to the below 50k
contracts
next one is around commercial contract
management and
it's been progressed we are working with
the trafford hr team to to recruit
somebody on a 12-month basis to to run
this program
for us and what they will do is look at
existing contracts and see where
we can um provide some savings they will
work closely with the finance teams and
service officers
um to deliver an action plan and deliver
that over the next 12 months so we're
hoping that to start
um early january and for a 12-month
piece of work nicola
yes so just in terms of ethics and
responsible procurement
um we um we're one of the first
authorities in the country to get the
corporate ethics mark and from sips
um that's an annual award so we're just
working through
the actions that we need to do to ensure
that we get that for another year which
includes um
annual training of everyone in the
procurement team
that helps us to deliver the cooperative
charter against modern slavery which all
four authorities have signed up to
we also do a continuous review of our
responsible procurement strategy
to ensure that it remains relevant and
reflects any new updates to any new
policies or um
schemes that our partners have signed up
to
so that gives you a bit of a snapshot of
some of the things that we are working
through
the recommendation of the report is that
you just note
the contents great thank you very much
nicola and elizabeth for both taking us
through that uh there's some really good
stuff in there i think it's that we're
celebrating and some really good
continuous work that will hopefully bear
fruit
um shortly allow us to see some future
improvement
um are there any questions or comments
to be made from the committee
i'm just trying to scan through my top
bar see if any hands are going up
council rush i've got councillor
councilman councilman
real thank you very much that that is a
really good report very exciting report
and particularly excited about the
work you're doing in trafford around
social value and that's really good to
see and hopefully it can be
um it could then spread out across the
other local authorities
um just a quick question and it wouldn't
be in this report it's a relatively new
thing but trafford
became a fair tax council um at our
meeting
a month or so ago and i just wondered
what early progress or what feedback
you've had
with regards to that change that we've
we've made in trafford
okay it'll be myself responding to that
please
and thank you um yes councillor ross
thank you because you you have actually
put us in touch with the fair tax team
and i have actually had a meeting with
them only a couple of weeks ago
just to really understand what what it
means and what it means in procurement
terms
so at the moment all we've done is
explore with them to understand
and the implication what what does it
mean in terms of
um traders obviously um not taxing
onshore and taxing offshore
and we're looking at how we can bring
that into procurement but we've got to
balance that obviously with with
how do we how do we prove it um do we
make it a mandatory clause within
procurement at the moment our view is it
might be um
sort of a a gentle way of bringing this
in where we you know we aspire to we
would like you to
rather than a mandate pass fail because
we think we could be challenged at the
moment
with that approach but we've met with
and the lady from the fair tax
mark and and that was a very helpful
meeting so it's on our agenda and we
will update you hopefully at the next
meeting
thank you very much eileen thank you
councillor
council mcgee um thank you chair
um so two points uh one um
the tableau scheme is uh is really
interesting
um you can look at a forest you can look
at an individual
tree and if you're really nerdy you can
look at three leaves together
um and that's the problem you need to
you know when i say the problem
um it's great for giving you either a
very you know a very good overview or
very detailed analysis
so um it is something that we're keen on
you know we're
we're using a lot more um i like the
idea of being an innovator and
achieving the corporate marks towards
the trip now is to keep them at that
level
of course and that requires constant
investment of time and staff doesn't it
to do that
which we i think would support
absolutely yes thank you council mcgee i
i agree with those comments elizabeth do
you want to come back
or nickler yeah
yes sorry um yeah it's about keeping it
um
consistent and and making sure that
that's that is through the team
and we have a dedicated person within
our team that
that runs that ethics ethics mark and um
he is definitely on the ball
um making sure that the team are
delivering that so
thank you any more comments questions oh
sorry nichola yes go ahead
so we just just on tableau and we do
have an sla with stockpot to help us
with um with tableau because they're
they've obviously implemented the system
um a couple of years ago so they do
support us and help us navigate through
the
leaves branches trees and forests with
us
good to hear about the branches yeah
there's so much nature and rambling
going on that's not what
that sounds good okay thank you very
much uh are we happy to note that report
then with the comments that have been
made yep seen lots of nods that's great
thank you
uh item seven urgent business if any
i've not been made aware of any urgent
business do we have any urgent business
that's been flagged to the committee
fabiola
not sure okay thank you
uh the date and time of the next meeting
this is item eight
and the next meeting will take place the
24th of march 2021
which sounds crazy to say doesn't it uh
at 10 a.m
um i'm now gonna move to item nine
which includes an exclusion resolution
uh of the present public from this
because we have to deal with the private
item
um are we happy to agree that committee
yes seen lots of nods thank you anybody
against
nope okay thank you fabiola can we end
the broadcast
yes sure